voilà c'est fini c'est fini c'est
chouette
un grand monsieur chez les massaï
sociale c'est plus fort que moi je me
fais à chaque fois sensiblerie on est
des hommes et poids breil
et voilà qu les plus méritants rouge va
tomber sur les modestes marionnettes que
nous sommes on va éteindre une à une
toutes ces lumières sur lesquels comme
des papillons nous étions plus vous
brûlez nous allons remonter dans notre
petite plage insalubre et on va faire
les comptes
honey pourcentage sur l'a7 n'est on
apprend à vérifier à l'obtenir sur la
brute
il enlève les taxes les droits d'auteur
et on restait porté au bord dont les
frais de publicité les pompiers de
service
je sais plus quoi encore c'est
dégueulasse mais qu'on donne à ces
normes
franchement vous êtes là
si toujours c'est ça qui compte le
public wii u qui souhaitent y a que ça
qui compte
voilà où est ce qui t mes copains place
à bureaux fermés on s'est bien marré
ensemble oui alors qu est ce qu on doit
rigoler on a du mérite parce que
vraiment la vie c'est pas gai c'est
dégueulasse telle société de merde fric
le fric le fric est venue des hyènes on
me disait
fait tellement de bien de temps en temps
de faire son autocritique ça les soirs
pas ce soir justement pas ce soir ce
soir vous comme ça les sort les voit pas
mais certains soirs en certains endroits
si on mettait un panneau entrée
interdite aujourd'hui ça se bousculait
pas la caisse pour ça qu'on ne met pas
par un peu fou
oh
en salle ce soir et un jour et tous
crever les familles ça louche on les
passera tous entre la bombe les
accidents de la route même maladie la
pollution on flatte la pourrait on va
pour et c'est dans tous les journaux
aux dernières nouvelles scélérat vous
fait il peur et qu'ils sont plus
nombreux
on n'a aucune chance de s'en tirer
à
à bientôt